time for a serious chat boys and girls
about your money a lot of you guys don't
have a lot of it and you are being taken
advantage of by these financial outlets
who are irresponsibly promoting to you
worthless things for clicks surprise
surprise i know i know we're all shocked
listen guys i want to have a serious
conversation with you guys based on some
things that i've been seeing not only
with a squid game crypto which went of
course could put after all these
mainstream outlets reported on it
endlessly breathlessly saying about how
much it was going up in value i want to
talk to you guys about just more than
just squid game crypto i want to talk to
you guys about the endless reporting of
meme coins and pitching of meme coins to
you things like
dogecoin shiba inu floki inu choose your
flavor of dog general coins with no
actual foundational value but who are
driven
entirely or almost entirely by marketing
hype where the only way the price goes
up is if we tell enough of our friends
and try to get them to fomo in and the
whole thing's built on like fear of
missing out and you know greater full
theory we've not only seen the explosion
of these types of cryptocurrencies not
only in the number of them but in the
value of them but we've also seen and
this is kind of surprising these things
go mainstream with mainstream outlets
whether it's youtubers or like actual
papers reporting on them seriously and
it's a joke and actually it led to one
of my favorite uh things ever which is
patrick boyle you guys might know as the
former hedge fund manager we interviewed
a while back watching him sort of break
down while talking about these coins you
can tell he's um about to cry i mean
we're very close to to breaking this
man's spirit watch him as he explains
one of these meme coins and what's
happening and just sort of feel the pain
of somebody who's spent their whole life
trying to understand something seeing it
get to this point these adverts are
supposed to drum up enthusiasm around
flocky new coin
the article goes on to say
the branding campaign aims to legitimize
the coin and increase confidence of the
average consumer the group's head of
marketing who identified himself by the
alias sabre said you get a lot of scam
artists in this game
yeah so that's what's going on in the
world of finance right now a man using
the alias sabre a name most likely
stolen from a comic book villain
is warning us against scam artists while
pitching his elon musk dog themed
currency he's been quoted in the
financial times a serious newspaper you
can almost see his soul breaking can't
you you almost see a single deer going
down buried in british sarcasm
the article continues flocky enu can
splash out on pricey advertising because
like some other meme coins it imposes a
marketing fee of four percent on buyers
that fee is used for onboarding
influencers and to further develop and
grow the flocky ecosystem i guess at
least they're onboarding influencers if
there's one thing that can be counted
upon to legitimize a new form of money
it's youtubers and instagramers because
after all this is finance in 2021. so
there you go guys at least we got that
beautiful reaction from our boy patrick
boyle go subscribe to his channel he
does like common sense investing but
yeah there there it is he's talking
about one of the big financial papers
the financial times just reporting on
this like absolute coin and you're just
like what has happened what
how did we get to this place i mean it's
one thing for these uh cryptocurrencies
to do promotional campaigns like this
built on nothing but fomo like miss doge
get floki it's literally selling fear
missing out that's like the pitch right
it's one thing to have that but to have
serious newspapers serious financial
um educators
right taking this these cryptos
seriously is absolutely insane so i
guess this is my way of saying like be
careful of all these videos talking
about sheba e new millionaires and
dogecoin millionaires and floki e new
millionaires and all this kind of stuff
because these guys are selling you
nothing but hype
fomo all this nonsense and it's like how
did we get to this point right how how
is this what like financial youtube is
financial twitter's about financial
articles are being written about these
things and it's like look i'm not saying
like don't cover these topics because
they're in the mainstream like
everybody's gonna talk about them to
some extent but you have to talk about
them in the context of like oh yeah
these are basically ponzi schemes right
like we all know these are ponzi schemes
but a lot of the people who talk about
this
they are just to get clicks they're
talking not about
why it's like a basically a ponzi scheme
and why it's relying on just greater
full theory instead they go oh it's up 2
000
oh it's up 10 000 could this be the next
you know huge coin or something like
that um when you're just pushing a
glorified like ponzi coin i mean so many
of these coins have no underlying
fundamentals and are literally built
purely on marketing how can you do that
to your fans like push them knowingly
into that i mean literally if that's all
finance is at this point we might as
well be telling people to go get lottery
tickets uh we might as well be telling
people you know just yeah go bet on such
and such lottery ticket i hear their
numbers are crazy today even though you
know it's a losing game these meme coins
have always been a losing game for most
people because they're built on nothing
developers take a huge cut early
adopters take most of it right if you're
finding out about it now you're late so
yeah i'm just basically putting this out
as a psa to my audience to anybody who
watches my channel um be careful of this
kind of like hype based news of like the
next shiba inu facebook sends the price
of this minor bitcoin rival soaring 300
percent to 6 billion like this kind of
writing is trash you're gonna get
wrecked on this kind of writing or at
least just realize like this is just the
same as basically buying lottery tickets
i mean you might as well buy lottery
tickets if you listen to this kind of
thing this article which is from forbes
compares shiba inu a meme coin to
bitcoin um okay i guess that's where
we're at these days oh and then it
mentioned squid game crypto which this
is before of course the crash talking
about it soaring even higher despite a
raft of serious warnings geez dude like
why is it all about you know how much
percent is it up when what it should be
about is like hey don't invest in a
ponzi coin hey maybe that's not a good
idea right so frustrating like again
these are financial outlets like they're
supposed to be like about financial
education it's so strange to watch this
like turn of events now real quick i
just wanted to jump in here steven from
the future here i realized i wanted to
make the caveat that i'm not talking
about anyone that covers finance ever
talking about these things is scamming
you or whatever i'm specifically talking
about people who pitch these things as
legitimate financial investments it's
perfectly fine to make fun of this stuff
it's perfectly fine to commentate on how
crazy it is that this stuff has gone
viral i'm specifically talking about the
financial people who are basically
talking about this in the way you talk
about any kind of investment talking
about this is a way to get rich or this
is a way that you're somehow going to
make a bunch of money that i think is
scummy just talking about it i think
it's fine fair game whatever okay
disclosure over i'm just in awe that
this is what personal finance has become
is like the discussion of meme coins
it's just it's so bizarre and while i
don't have his sense of british wit i
share his sort of like dread over it
because here's the thing i know these
things seem like they last forever so
you go oh gotta get in the bubble while
i still can they eventually pop and then
people just get wrecked and all of these
uh
outlets
articles people they'll cover you
getting wrecked but they're not they're
not gonna cover the cost dude and unlike
them who usually can afford this kind of
thing who usually are making money on
top of this kind of thing you guys can't
like most of the people who are getting
targeted with these types of
cryptocurrencies they don't have a bunch
of spare money like it's talking to my
barber my barber is invested in dogecoin
whatever and you're just kind of like
you know you know they don't have a ton
of discretionary income we are targeting
like masses of regular people with not a
ton of discretionary income and we are
selling them worthless coins that are
built on ponzinomics i don't know seems
wrong to me but then again here i am
maybe it's a little boomer of me not to
understand the genius of meme coin
economics dude maybe it'll be different
this time i know we've been through so
many speculative bubbles and every one
of them has popped but maybe
floki enu is the new one you know maybe
they're going to be the exception uh but
i don't think so anyways stay safe with
your money out there guys a lot of
stupid stupid reports going out there
they're getting people wrecked and i
just i just want you guys to be safe
with your money and stay away from
articles like this that are just click
baiting and trying to sell you like meme
coin garbage anyways
that rant over thanks for watching
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
balling